It's always been this way with her.
The more I get, the happier
I am, the more resentful she becomes. Mom.
Take a deep breath.
I'm just so sorry
you even had to witness that
Auntie Vy,
said a lot of hurtful
things. Awful things.
Have you ever stopped to ask yourself why?
Maybe underneath all of that
Anger.
She's just hurt?
What? Vy has made of steel.
Vy put myself through college,
Vy raised Will on her own, Vy--
took care of mom on her own.
She's just been doing everything.
Yeah.
That's just--
a heavy expectation to put on someone,
don't you think?
I've been doing this to her whole life.
Mom, I think that you and your sister
need to have a talk.
You know, without all the insults.
Of course.
So when did you get so wise?
I think it was the 100th time
you told me to make it work with Will.
Because we're family.
I didn't mean to ruin your party
like that.
I really didn’t.
Mom.
You do know that there's no way in hell
anyone could ever rid you from my life.
Ever.
Thank you, baby.
You know, in my mind,
I had planned this wonderful trip
to celebrate your birthday,
and your aunt Viv just got under my skin.
Look, I love you, Mom,
but you can't put that all on Viv,
because you were throwin some low blows in
there too. I was only trying to defend myself.
You know, she crossed the line first and
so what?
You're here waiting for an apology.
I guess this is the part where you tell me
I should be the bigger person.
I mean,
it's good advice.
Will, do you mind if I speak to my sister
alone for a moment?
Make me proud.
You're right.
I haven't always acknowledged
how much I received.
And relied on your mother.
I've been unfair to both of you.
I mean,
you're always the strong one
looking out for me.
I’m so sorry for seeing past that.
Can you ever forgive me?
Yes, of course.
You're my sister.
Besides,
I can't pin all my disappointments on you.
I made my choices.
And one of them was Lou.
I'm sorry I didn't listen to you.
I'm sorry that
I held it against you all these years.
You were right about him.
Believe me, I wish I wasn't.
Me too.
But he did give me a gift
that I'll always be thankful for.
Will.
He is so special.
Yeah,
He's a fine young man.
That is why I've decided
not to do anything to tamper with that.
So were gonna wait to tell him about Lou?
Yeah, Maybe down the road.
I love you.
Viv.
I know.
Girl, I love you, too.
Come on.